[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where dad
is down cassius king and the paid off
home mortgage has taken the place of the
bmw as the status symbol of choice ken
coleman ramsey personality number one
best-selling author and host of the ken
coleman show is my co-host today as we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships thank you for joining us
american we're so glad you're with us
tell a friend that we're here and spread
the word for us open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
the number again triple eight eight two
five five two two five mike is in boise
hey mike welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave thanks for having me on i
really appreciate it my pleasure sir how
can we help
well i
got a quick question regarding a second
home and i'm wondering if
i am sacrificing too much
to hang on to that home
uh from a financial standpoint
okay
what's the sacrifice
well um so
for from a money standpoint net income
we bring in approximately
5 thousand a month five to fifty three
hundred a month that's take home pay
that is take home pay okay um
because of the second home
it requires i need about 6 200 a month
when i take into account all the
expenses that the second home causes
so i'm able to
i do a little side hustle and i can work
overtime at work
but in order to afford that 60 200 a
month i have to work some overtime or do
my side hustle to make that extra money
and i'm just wondering at what point
i'm i'm working too much to hang on to
the second home rather than just sell it
and enjoy some other things right now
[Music]
what's the trajectory of your
main income is it going to go up
substantially in the next couple years
or is this a temporary thing or is it
going to be gradual increase
well i would say my my main income won't
substantially increase however in about
four years i will retire which will give
me access to
all of my retirement accounts at that
point in time i could simply pay off the
second home which would have about a
hundred thousand dollars remaining at
that point
um so at that point in four years it
becomes easy again
i'm just kind of wondering between now
and that
that four year mark
how much is in your retirement accounts
um well first of the year i was just
over a million so it's probably around
800 000 at this point i haven't looked
recently
uh but somewhere around how old are you
i am currently 50 i'll retire at 54. i'm
a firefighter
and you have access to this type of
account without penalty
that's my understanding yes uh it's a
401k as well as a 457 and i believe
because of my
occupation there's a
law that allows me to access it early i
think that's true um
so what is the house what's it worth the
second home
um i would say roughly 800 000.
wow
it's in a pretty desirable kind of
vacation area so it's like a mountain
house or what
mountain house yes
the home you're worth living is worth
what
um probably close to that maybe a little
less seven to seven fifty i would guess
so you're a sixty thousand dollar a year
all right well that's take home pay an
eighty thousand 000 a year
multi-millionaire
i guess yeah now and from a net worth
standpoint yeah that's how you measure
net worth that's how you measure
millionaires net worth yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah i feel pretty fortunate i just so
how much do you i mean
at the start of this call i was getting
ready to say dump this thing but it
starts to sound like a really nice place
to be
and you've got the money um it's just
you can't get to it right now
right and so are you willing to pay pay
the price of four years of overtime to
hang on to it it's a it's a values
judgment on your part there's not a dumb
there's not a dumb box we check in this
you sell it you're dumb you don't sell
it you're dumb that's neither one of
those is true okay you're not done
you've you've done a great job i i feel
like i'm hearing either uh some physical
tiredness or maybe emotional tiredness
is that true
i think maybe some emotional i i can
continue to work i'm i'm not afraid to
work
i think just emotionally sometimes and i
think it stems from the point that we
don't use it very much and so i just
wonder why am i continuing to pay this
much are you gonna use it at retirement
well i sure hope so uh i hope we'll use
it more than we do now
but it's unknown you know it's just
unknown
well at the point you're not using the
thing then it changes the entire
conversation so
um you know it sounds like it might be a
dream from the past not a dream for the
future
i think i would agree with that i think
we always wanted to have one when our
kids were young and now they're um
college age
um
and i just yeah we always wanted one
when they were young and we didn't have
it that at that point and now we have
sell it but yeah i hear it i hear that
all over you sell it yeah
okay all right it's not bringing you joy
it's that whatever that woman is that
says does this thing bring you joy thing
right
and yeah it's not bringing you joy right
and so yeah dump the thing it's not it's
the past it's a real it's a memory now
here's the thing
nothing is forever when it comes this
kind of stuff this particular property
will be gone but you're going to be
sitting on several million dollars when
you retire
and that that will buy you a week in a
mountain house
anytime you want to go
yeah okay so like we rented a a like a
15 000 square footer on the slopes at
crested butte and took all of our family
and way too many of their friends and
everything else up there is a beautiful
home and
i didn't have to own the thing i just
bought it for the week
you know it was great it was expensive
week but it's a lot less than eight
hundred thousand bucks i can tell you
that
and you know so you can go to the
mountains to a mountain house any time
you want dude yeah uh just not this one
and and and if you really really miss it
you can go buy a four or five hundred
thousand dollar one after retirement and
not blink
yep yep agreed i'm i'm done yeah i'm
done get rid of that thing man yeah no
question it's gonna it's gonna set a
woman's name marie conde
help me with this uh condo marine condo
yeah does this give you joy yeah it's
hilarious i love that yeah because it's
the op is she's like a a alternative a
sweet version of the minimalist or
something yeah oh is that the
crap get everything ordered in your
house to give you peace or something
yeah oh yeah get rid of the crap it's an
organizer yeah yeah
you can tell i'm completely not her
market but yeah i think stacy mentioned
that once and i may have seen it in
passing walking through the list
the concept is right though i like what
she says i like that i like the concept
is does this give you joy and
at the point here is it's a trade-off
it's it's a lot of work to pay and he's
almost got it paid off it's aggravating
it's within reach but even then you
nailed it though you could feel got to
maintain the stupid thing yeah and this
is good he's he's going to be great
financially now he's gonna have this
bird being done right now yeah on my
lake house yeah even if it's all paid
off you've got the more crap you own the
more repairmen you have to know but i
like my lake house so i'm fine with a
little bit of painting being done down
there today but you just you know yeah
does this thing there's always a
trade-off and
yeah get rid of it
it ceased to be fun some time ago
this is the ramsey show
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Applause]
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five
five two two five well we know uh with
talk of inflation and uh actual
inflation and when you go to the gas
pump you have a minor freaking heart
attack we know with the recession having
hit not much a one but it is a recession
it's kind of a wimpy little result it's
like a baby recession a little tiny baby
misty recession but it's here and so uh
we know with all that it can be scary
uh and with that oh now you can get real
scared and i'm out of control with my
money yeah now you can get real scared
and how am i going to retire and how am
i going to get rid of these student
loans okay
you don't have to live like this
you have to get to the point where you
say enough is enough
and decide to make some big changes
because uh you can't keep doing the same
things you've always done and expect
different results that's the definition
of insanity that means it's trying the
time to try financial peace university
uh you're going to learn the proven
step-by-step plan to actually
win with money
and when you follow the plan you'll not
only get out of debt build wealth but
become outrageously generous learn to
work with your spouse on the money and
man the whole subject starts to be a
smile instead of a frown
so uh if you've ready to say i've had
enough
then i go to ramseysolutions.com
and we'll get you into financial peace
university almost 10 million people have
done this
ramsey solutions.com slash
enough
time to get with it tyler is with us
tyler's in tallahassee
florida hi tyler welcome to the ramsey
show
hey thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
hey so i'm a uh a farmer and
i'm a young guy i'm only 27
and i also work full time
for a uh in like a maintenance position
and um
i've i've grown my business and it's
been kind of like a side hustle in a way
and it's never really made money and
then this year we we made around a
hundred thousand dollars wow and um
profit for our blueberry season yeah we
grow blueberries and so
we had a really good year and i'm kind
of torn
now i'm i i've worked for five years or
six years now i'm building this business
up
and it's it's always been a dream to
make make it work and it's made i've
made it work and now i'm like what do i
do next and so
i've got some questions about um
what do i do with this money
um i have some debt um i have a truck
payment and we actually owe a little bit
on our farm
both of those uh combined are up i think
it's forty five thousand almost to the
dot
forty five thousand one hundred
um so do i pay that off yes
um
well another thing is i have
uh so blueberries are very
they're kind of a a specialty crop and
you have to be careful with them because
frost in florida north florida frost can
really damage them
and so i've been i've been squeaking by
i don't have the frost protection
that i need which is going to cost like
70 000 now because you know the price of
everything is going through the roof and
it's
90
pvc pipe and you know that's just going
through the roof with prices so do i
spend the money on that or do i get out
of debt
i mean how many acres
how many acres have you gotten
blueberries
um it's six acres right now
but i want to expand and that's that's
the other side of the question
i've made money and i'm to the point now
where i can't grow any more until i do
this full time i've either got to
you know
or get off the pot and i don't know what
to do there because i either work
full-time
i'm working full-time right now you know
seven to five
and then i go and to do my farm and how
predictable is this crop annually
uh it's pretty predictable with frost
protection i mean the so what what is
why is this the first time in five years
you've made this money
well i've i've started the business so
when you start it you your plants are
really tiny and then they have to grow
for three years and it just takes money
and and so we we started with a dream me
and my wife and we had carried some land
and now we've got the land it took us a
couple years to get the well and
everything get the money together and
then you know five years comes along
this is just our first
profitable year
it's your first real crop yeah
yes sir
i understand that what do you make in
your day job
about 41 000 is that gross
yeah that's great all right i would work
one more year
and i would pay off all the debts today
and i would put in 50
of the uh
frost protection
three acres yeah
well i thought about that but the
problem is you have to put a large well
in and so the the water is you basically
are irrigating the whole six acres
you're making it rain out there a
quarter of an inch of rain per hour
and so i it's either all or nothing i
can't do half of it no
no
the well is not the whole i mean you put
the well in and put some of the pipe in
but you don't have the money to do the
whole thing and you don't need to do
this or you do not you do not need to
borrow money to do frost protection and
effectively when you've got borrowed
money on the land and borrow money on
the truck and how much is your truck
worth
um it's
in today's market who knows it's a 2019
f-150
how many miles no that's like a 60 000
truck right
i would say like 45 now probably i don't
know i hadn't looked in a while sell it
okay and do the front protection
well get an old truck
tractors don't care how new the truck is
the only person that cares is the
redneck behind the wheel
well this is our our mainly our only
truck i'm not going to argue with you
you make 41 000 a year you're driving a
truck it's too stinking expensive
yeah it's crazy
it's nuts
and you need to get rid of the truck and
get your frost protection in go make you
some money and then get you a nice truck
later
but get you a work truck right now
like real farmers use not pretend ones
yeah nobody that's a very good point the
tractor doesn't care and you're you know
your family doesn't care there's no
value out of that listen i he's dodged
the bullet you've dodged the bullet to
this point on the frost i understand it
but paying off i am not going to tell
you to use this money yes to put in the
frost protection and keep the debt yeah
and drive that truck i'm not going to
tell you to do that it's not what i
would do if i were in your shoes you've
worked too hard to get to this point and
the crop is at risk because of the truck
you drive
not because you're unwilling not because
of debt
so get rid of the stupid truck now you
got the money ta-da
just like that it all worked out yeah
it's simple except for that ego part
yeah on the truck but yeah i mean it's
just
yeah and then i want to address he asked
the question hey i also want to by the
way i drive a nice truck
and i don't mind you having a nice truck
but the night you know the truck is way
down the list of things that i care
about in this conversation i care about
this crop this business
i care about growing getting the frost
protection on it so we can stabilize the
predictability of the crop coming in the
business model is firmed up considerably
when you do that now next time you make
a whole bunch of money you can quit work
move up and trust me and buy acreage
that's exactly right with next year's
crop that's right so that's when you
make the move tyler full time you've got
all the other stuff paid for no debt and
now you can pay yourself more than what
you're actually making in your day job
it's a math it's a math equation you
don't have the money to pay your bills
if you quit and use this money for frost
protection and debt reduction that's
correct so you've got to work one more
year at least and when the crop comes in
next time set that money asset
a year's worth of living expenses aside
yeah and then use the rest to expand the
business i just wouldn't be in a hurry
you know and i agree you can do it in a
year but even two years just stock stock
that money up only 27 26 yeah
yep that's what i would do it's an
interesting call man thank you thanks
for sharing all that with us that's i'm
happy for all your success too by the
way i love blueberries dave high in
antsy antioxidants just in case you were
keeping score i'm you're not you you
like the blueberry you and my health
food wife will have to discuss this
stuff sharon knows about blueberries i
don't know about it unless it's bad for
you
and i have consumed it recently so there
you go
and i have the physique to prove it so
shut up i'm not saying anything i know
isn't it time to go to way too smart for
that turn the commercial up turn the
bump music up
this is the ramsey shop
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman number one best-selling
author ramsey personality and host of
the ken coleman show is my co-host today
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage jason and nicole are
with us hey guys how are you good doing
great good to see you guys good to see
you where do you all live st petersburg
florida oh nice welcome to nashville and
here to do a debt-free scream how much
did you pay off
we paid off 245 thousand dollars yay and
how long did that take just over two and
a half years whoa you're getting it and
your range of income during that time we
made between 225 to 275 000. nice what
do y'all do for a living well i'm an
account executive for a large home
health care company
real estate agent and property
management ah good time to be in that
world yeah good so 245 thousand dollars
was what kind of debt that was our house
you paid off
that's right looking at weirdos sure i
love it good for you well done guys
thank you so what in the world started
this journey two and a half years ago
and get after it man you knocked it out
fast
yeah well i uh we were kind of inching
along being dave ish for about the past
five years we we already had our house
on a 15-year mortgage we had no credit
card debt we had the cars paid for we
just had that mortgage left
and kind of looked at each other and
said why don't we just knock this thing
out and uh we certainly have the income
to do it and so we sit down and made a
plan and got the family involved and and
that's what set it off about two and a
half years ago yeah you're making banks
so why not knock it out exactly you look
down you're going ah that's doable right
yeah so how much did that change the
payments what was that new sacrifice and
new commitment oh every
every
ounce of money we had left we threw at
the mortgage so eight or eight or ten
thousand bucks a month exactly yeah
every bonus i got every spring i would
go to the bank and gladly pay my entire
bonus on the mortgage for the past
couple of years and
we made a big deal out of it actually we
got the kids involved with our debt-free
jar so two and a half years ago we put
245 skittles in the jar counted them out
one by one
and everybody made a little note of what
their dream vacation would be once we
got the debt-free jar empty so there's
some little pieces of paper floating
around in here that everybody made their
dream vacation on and every paycheck
have we read the dream vacations we have
yeah right so what were the kids
vacation dreams
you t you have to tell us they're not on
mike you tell us tyler wanted to go to
ford wilderness camping i want to go
camping at disney yeah and sophia wanted
to go to lego land
that's good those are those good choices
what about you two
well i wanted to go to europe mm-hmm
what part greece italy yeah nice that's
still on the list maybe next summer okay
and mine was to drive across country and
make a stop here to do our debt-free
screen so
see now there you go i mean now we know
yeah there it is yeah we didn't drive we
ended up flying up here but yeah that's
all right we made a job man very cool
very cool well i'll i'll choose greece
and italy
yeah
next summer yeah
the good news is you don't have to make
a choice you do them all that's correct
so there we go good and so we empty the
skittles and here we are that's right i
love it very good guys very good i got
to know who ate the last skittle oh
that would be sophia okay way to go
sofia very nice what color was it do we
remember
i believe it was yellow okay i think
there's a picture she confirmed that it
was yellow they actually helped made the
last payment
they each pitched in ten dollars
to make the last payment nice yeah we
were sure i mean
is on the on the it's on the table here
so we gotta knock this thing out gotta
have some skin in there we don't wanna
make 20 bucks short that's right yeah
it's good good for you all well done
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of that is
i mean
stay with it and just you know it's hard
sometimes because you see other people
going on vacations and buying nice cars
and you still drive that minivan that is
bent up and old and full of the cereals
and
just
keep on
keep on looking forward yeah you're
getting there at some point
not trying to keep up with the joneses i
have a 15 year old truck she's got the
minivan and so we could obviously have
bought better vehicles along the way but
getting out of debt was way more
important than the car we drive or the
clothes we wear so just living within
our means and well and if you drive like
no one else later you can drive like no
one else exactly i mean when you get
back from greece you can go get a better
car yeah you're used to putting 18 grand
a month on stuff you can save up money
pretty quick now that's right good good
i love this yeah i i it's really great
so i'm curious to know when you guys
were you said you were dave ish but you
guys were doing fantastic then you said
okay we're taking on the house and that
kind of switch to serious commitment how
long did it take or was it just i mean
did you catch the momentum at some point
or was it really hard at first when you
start to make that extreme sacrifice i
think it was hard at first but we we
sort of set up some systems to ensure
that it would happen like i like to call
it forced budgeting with auto direct
deposit and free online checking
accounts we had a couple of different
accounts we had our mortgage account we
had our discretionary spending account
we had our bills account and i knew
exactly how much was going into each
account every month automatically it
keeps you from accidentally bleeding
over exactly so that extra mortgage
payment would go in every month it would
automatically sweep out
and then again when i got my bonus every
spring i would just go and pay that off
so
yeah when you can put smart on autopilot
that's a good thing yep yeah because a
lot of us put dumb on autopilot that's
right and uh but if you can put smart on
autopilot that's a big deal way to go
guys way to go how does it feel to be
completely free feels fantastic
yeah
i mean you can see another car real easy
right yeah yeah no no he's already been
throwing some hints around yeah
good yeah well i heard him i heard the
hands i hope you're picking up on them
yeah that's the key it's gonna
uh just over a million whoa yep so you
are baby steps a millionaire that's
right not even counting the retirement
which i hadn't even asked about yet how
much is in there a couple 100 about 300.
okay wow there we go y'all yeah
y'all uh we're in our mid-40s i'm a
little bit older than she is yeah and
your baby steps millionaires with a paid
four million dollar house fantastic
i love it yeah that's it that's how you
do it right there man yeah i like it i
like it i like it all right we've got a
copy of baby steps millionaires the book
for you uh since you are living it and
uh also we're gonna give you a
one-year subscriber membership to uh
financial peace university and of course
uh you can give that away to somebody
that's trying to get started or you can
go through it it's got the new videos in
it with dr john delony and rachel cruz
and george campbell and me it's the best
videos we've ever done so it's a great
version of it and a copy of total money
makeover as well a lot of people get
started with that and you can hand that
out to somebody that's inspired by your
situation all right let's bring uh
sophia and tyler up and what are their
ages sophia is ten
tyler's eight all right very cool very
cool good looking family
beautiful beautiful well done
all right
jason and nicole sophia and tyler they
are without skittles
245 000 paid off housing everything
making them baby steps millionaires two
and a half years it took them making two
and a quarter to 275. count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three
three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
man
you know it is interesting to me that
when you
you you just something happens that
caused you to look
over there and go wait a minute
we can do that
you know it was kind of sitting there
before
but they go with our income and this
debt we can do that we can it's just
just the realization that it's possible
makes you go well then we should i agree
yeah because they'd already been very
smart been very financially sound and
then they go okay and this is what makes
this family very special is because it
took a lot of sacrifice so they're
they're they're moving along making
really good income and then to all of a
sudden go you know what we're gonna
climb this final mountain we really want
to pay this house off we want to you
know we want to receive the benefits of
what that's going to do for us to make
us baby steps millionaires to put us on
a path to truly building crazy wealth
and then go it's going to be really hard
and he said it was hard at first yeah
and and yet he said you know what we're
going to automate it
the automated discipline i love that
that was a wonderful we're going to set
some dreams yeah
you know where you can travel to if you
don't have any payments anywhere you
want that's right that's what you can do
right there anywhere you want you know
what you can drive if you don't have any
payments almost anything you want oh my
gosh
wow i really hope they have uh they take
a big pack of skittles to grease with
them
i think that's important i i don't you
don't i don't you don't like the
skittles i think skittles are fine but i
don't know i don't think it's necessary
in greece
i'm just i'm just saying i think i'm
just talking about a theme that's all i
know just a silly theme
it's over the skittles are gone they're
gone it's done this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author and host of the
ken coleman show is my co-host today
open phones a triple h 825
5
2 2 5.
you know what i didn't say in that last
segment and i should have but i realized
even more when we walked out to meet
that couple at the break they just did
their debt-free scream
um
they completely changed their family
tree not just because of the numbers but
those two kids
are dialed in
they are involved emotionally
intellectually they know what's gone on
and he had two extra total money
makeover books that he had purchased
one that we were assigned to the little
young man and one to the young lady and
he's going to give them to them later to
remind them again yes so not only is the
lesson taught but it's going to be
reinforced later as they head into
adulthood
and
i pity the young man
that wants to date little sophia later
who has a car payment i agree be like be
like trying to take one of my daughters
out you know in high school right yeah i
love that
you have a car payment
keep on stepping pal you know it is a
credit to the intentionality of those
parents yeah intentional well it's it's
it's they'll never forget this moment
those kids won't they're old enough
truly
a changed family tree true
john is with us john's in reno nevada
hey john how are you
doing well how are you better than i
deserve what's up
so i know you say never buy a new car um
i'm in a bit of a unique situation no i
say never buy a new car to get a million
dollar net worth
so i've been wanting to get a truck for
a while um i have a pre-order
reservation for a rivien truck which is
this electric truck coming on the market
yeah um because i put a reservation in a
while ago my reservation price is like
seventy eight thousand current price is
now 100 000.
um i'm wondering if i should be
considering buying this truck um below
20 like 20 below msrp or if i should get
something used like a tacoma or a ranger
for about half the price i'll be paying
cash for either want to get your
thoughts what's your net worth
uh
about five to six hundred k
you should buy a used car
all right
you know why
because
new cars go down in value particularly
brand new
the next delorean
which this riven may be
i don't think it's the next ford or
chevy
it might be the next tesla which would
be a good thing for you but it could be
the next delorean you know what a
delorean is right oh yeah the car and
back to the future greatest car in movie
history dave yeah it's also not made
anymore
that's true it's it's now a prop yeah
and so you know i don't know what's
going to happen these trucks i have no
idea i'm not an expert on that uh but
you're you know not only are you buying
a brand new truck not but you're also
buying an electric truck which is a
cutting edge thing and you're gonna buy
a brand that is a brand new brand
uh and it's in its infancy and we have
no freaking idea what the value of this
thing is going to be five years from
today
and so you can't afford to take a hit
that's 50 grand when you only have a
half you're going to lose 10 percent of
your net worth screwing around with an
electric truck
maybe
maybe not but maybe um
normally cars go in half in four years
normal cars do from msrp
and so if this thing maintains a normal
pattern
uh
not worse than normal i'm predicting i
think you've got a high probability of
worse than normal but if it maintains a
normal pattern
then um
you know i just don't
yeah so
uh no i wouldn't do it but but you're
gonna do it
uh you already knew what we're gonna say
for you called
and so you're gonna do it
but i wouldn't and there's my reasoning
yeah well he called you and asked you
gave him a formula and you got the
chuckle i had picture in his head going
back it was a chuckle like
yeah because he's going he's going hey
but there's a reason why you have that
formula there's a reason why the
percentage that you apply to them that's
what i want people to get if you if you
it's i mean i
it's a math thing right you know when
you lose your butt
on stuff and you only have one butt
it's
it's a problem you know that's one way
you know when you when you lose 50 grand
and you only have 500 000 to your name
yeah that's a lot of money it's
depreciating you're losing you've got
too many things going the wrong way
while you're trying to build wealth yeah
and uh that's straight up consumption
is what it is and there's nothing wrong
with consumption there's nothing wrong
with having a toy and if you want to
spend your money on that truck that's
fine
i mean my buddy of mine just bought one
of those things and i hadn't gotten a
ride in it yet but um you know and i i'm
not gonna get one it's not my taste but
that doesn't get anything to do with it
but the the point is my buddy the guy
that bought it he's worth about 15
million dollars yeah if the battery
catches fire like a tesla and just burns
the thing to the ground it isn't going
to kill him as long as he's not in it i
mean he's not going to bother him
financially he could take whatever 100
000 bucks out in the backyard and burn
it and it doesn't
he's got 10 million it's but but when
you only got a half a million and you're
you know you got a probability a high
probability of losing at least 50 000
bucks then that's why i tell people not
to buy new cars when
because they go down in value like a
rock that's where chevy got that like a
rock
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five george is with us
george in orlando hi george how are you
hey dave and ken nice to talk to you
guys our true pleasure
my our pleasure as well sir how can we
help
okay so i got a question i bought a home
a few years back me and my my current
wife were dating i bought the home uh
under my name
now that we're married
should i or can i
uh do like a a claimed deed to add her
name to
the house or how can i do that what what
do you guys recommend
uh if you want to in most states you can
do what's called a quit claim deed
deeding her an undivided marital
interest
uh it usually is very inexpensive less
than a hundred dollars to prepare and
less than a hundred dollars to record it
at the courthouse if you want to go
through that it depends on florida law
and i don't know florida law well enough
to tell you on this but a a good real
estate agent or a an attorney real
estate attorney that you have that's a
friend of yours just answer a question
for you in tennessee in our state
uh when you are married and it's the
principal residence whether your wife is
on the deed or not she owns half of it
oh okay if i got ready to say if my
house is deeded in my name and i got
ready to sell it and i'm married
she has to sign off she has half
interest owner by law without even
having her name on the deed in our state
and it's that way in a lot of states
in other words she got nothing to worry
about if that's the way it is in florida
you don't have to go through all this
but if you wanted to do it as a symbolic
thing almost it shouldn't be that
expensive just get with a title company
or a real estate attorney and ask them
how inexpensively they could do a quit
claim deed and it's just for an
undivided marital interest it's very
simple and it just basically
puts up in the public eye as a public
recording at the courthouse
that you are
uh that you're an owner or that she's an
owner at that point you're including her
there but um so can the rule with what's
happening in real estate is
um
what's at the courthouse is all that
matters
if it's not recorded at the courthouse
it didn't happen wow it's uh if you have
a deed that was never recorded and it's
in the drawer at home
you don't have a deed
you don't have title of the property
you're not the owner of the property the
recording at the courthouse is what
gives you
ownership in every state now in this
case marital ownership may be there by
law and that would be kind of an
exception to that but um
but just keep in mind if your name is
not recorded at the courthouse as the
owner of the property unless you have a
marital interest by law
then you are not the owner of the
property and uh i'm shocked at how many
people think they own something
in real estate that have not bothered to
go ahead and
is the courthouse is that a function of
when they did the closing they're
closing
a legal team or whatever no usually it's
some inner family garbage something's
passed right like my you know my daddy
showed me this but i never went down
recorded the deed well you didn't you
don't own it but you know that's right
that's typically where that crap comes
up oh okay but if there's a closing
attorney title company involved they're
pretty judicious about getting it all
done properly at the courthouse
so there you go
ah that puts this hour of the ramsey
show in the books our thanks to austin
ben zack andrew and james and kelly in
the booth ken coleman my co-host we'll
be back with you before you know it
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
that is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they really love and create actual
amazing relationships
thank you for joining us america ken
coleman ramsey personality number one
best-selling author of the book paycheck
to purpose and also host of the ken
coleman show here on the ramsey networks
is my co-host today we are answering
your questions todd is in los angeles hi
todd welcome to the ramsay show
hello hi what's up
um well
i'm calling because uh
i'm a special education teacher
um at a local high school and
i'm interested in increasing my my
income and i'm kind of on the fence as
far as
what's the best strategy to do that
well do you have a plan as to where you
would go from that special education uh
position what's that ladder look like or
what are you considering
well there's a couple things that bounce
around in my head that one of them is
trying to take on a second job in the
evenings and weekends
so i could increase my income that way
it would be like kind of an immediate
fix but
at the same time
i need to sleep and i need
you know i think i'd be really exhausted
if i did that sure um
and i think that would probably
i could probably
earn approximately 50 000 or more a year
okay um
the other option is something i've been
thinking about and that would be going
back to school to get like my phd in
psychology or something like that
um
and the motivation with that is i've got
experience working with
um
you know
students with autism and learning
disabilities so i'm already kind of
dealing with a neurocognitive type stuff
and i think um
if i were to go back and get a
degree in psychology
i think i would have more opportunities
to earn significantly more okay so
that's the exercise so you're already
down that path you just have to confirm
this if you get a phd in psychology what
does that now qualify you for
as it relates to stepping up the ladder
and an extension of what you're already
doing you have to know that it's not
something where we pre we prospect on
that that's a lot of time and money for
you to go get a phd even if you got the
cash for it we don't want you to go into
debt and so you got to know that you
know there's a simple construct that i
will give to you that i give to
everybody who's considering school is it
the only way to go where you want to go
and you're not really clear yet and you
need to get a little bit clearer on here
are some options for me option a b or c
when you finish this degree what are you
going to be doing for your day job every
day that makes you a living and what
does it pay and does it require the
degree that's the exercise
right now you've kind of got this well
if i had a degree i'd probably be worth
more money not really that's yeah
probably not
because you'll be one of those aimless
people with degrees out there wandering
in the traffic again
yeah okay because you here's the deal
here's the good news you may not need a
higher ed degree to make more money
you you know you've got to play this out
it's that simple is it the only one if
you want to be a licensed psychologist
you're going to have at least a masters
in psychology in every state now
so um you know that is that's that's
permission to play there that's table
stakes
so uh you know so you need to identify
exactly when this is over what you will
be doing for a living that's it if you
want to get a phd and go back and teach
in college fine if you want to do
research fine if you want to be doing
therapy on a daily basis fine then what
degree is required for the knowledge
base and for licensing that sets you up
to win yeah you don't you don't pick a a
a a mode of transportation
and then decide where you want to go
you decide where you want to go multiple
options now what's the best way to get
there so you're on the right track but
you've got the order flipped and it's
that simple then we decide oh okay great
what can i make here
will i enjoy the work
check yes what does it take to get
qualified to do it now now i put the
plan together to climb the mountain so
and i would say this in the short term i
would choose between exhaustion
and making the same amount of money i
also there's a narrative there that i
want to challenge you on todd to make
more money you don't have to choose
exhaustion
you know i understand you can work some
extra hours but you don't have to choose
exhaustion you can go all right i'm not
going to work myself into oblivion and
be burned out physically mentally and
emotionally but i'm going to work
some hours more to bring in some more
income i choose that as you're making
the decision yeah
and and again that may be how you fund
school
that's what i'm thinking that's a
possibility so then then it becomes you
got a reason to
take the extra hours just generally
speaking i want to work on a part-time
job so i have more money yeah
not unless you have something to do with
the money
again very goal-oriented very
intentional
in every step and in the direction that
you're going katie is in cincinnati hi
katie welcome to the ramsey show
hi guys how are you great what's up
um first of all i just want to say thank
you we've paid off 60 000 in debt in the
last two years i'm super excited about
that great very much
and my question is um so basically i am
a photographer by trade i work full-time
for a big corporate company and i'm i've
been here for four years and just
recently got back from maternity leave
and
had been working towards getting a
promotion at this job but then when i
got back they had hired
someone else
to basically take on the lead position
here so i'm kind of in this spot where i
feel like i'm not progressing in this
career or in this company basically
and i'm trying i'm starting to kind of
toss around the idea of possibly going
out and branching out on my own and
freelance but i'm i'm i guess what i'm
trying to ask is i'm kind of nervous to
do it in a way but also because we're
paying off debt i don't want to like
hinder any of that so i'm just trying to
figure out a way like is this the right
move should i do that or should i just
like kind of like grin and bear it for
the next foreseeable future
well i think that's a conversation that
you as a family union have got to make
have a conversation on that i i would
lean towards sticking it out where you
are so that when you go into full-time
photography to work for yourself you do
not have this massive pressure and and
you put all this pressure on yourself
when you go okay i'm going to go work
for myself and we've got this debt
snowball we're still working through and
i don't think that's going to allow you
to be a as creative as you need to be
and i think it's going to allow it's
going to put a lot of pressure on you
and you don't need that what i would do
is stay where you are and i would start
doing some photography on the side to
increase the rate of which we're paying
off the debt yeah start to start as a
side hustle and now that sets you up to
make the to make the transition once you
guys have paid off the debt and got the
emergency fund fully funded
yeah and i'm doing that now too so i
just was like my gosh i'm
i love doing what i do i just have
gotten to this point where i feel like
i'm pushing and pushing and pushing to
get to this you know i think that's the
bigger issue let's let's throw out the
truth that i'm hearing okay if i'm in
your shoes this is how i would be
okay
you just had a baby
and
when you went back to work they hurt
your feelings yes
which means you're like a human
right yeah
that's a normal reaction to what
happened to you at the worst possible
time and so you're just kind of
both sad and mad at the same time and
you want to give them the finger but i'm
going to be an adult and not do that
right now i'm going to hang out there
get my act together and then just stroll
out the door when i'm ready
don't get discouraged stay disciplined
and remember you're doing all of this to
not pay off debt only but also to do
your dream job down the road
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today number one best-selling
author on the line our good friend
pastor craig groschel from lifechurch.tv
lifechurch.com in oklahoma city pastor
craig how are you my friend
hey dave hey ken i'm doing great how are
you guys doing great man doing great
another book proud of you sir hey thank
you thank you you and i were talking
about this book a little while uh back
when we were together knowing that it
was coming and i'm really really excited
about it it's called lead like it
matters with the it circled seven
leadership principles for a church that
lasts but leadership principles are
leadership principles whether you're
running a church or running a business
right
right absolutely i learned from uh
business leadership every day the the
principles transfer and i think that
although this is written two church
leaders i think i'm i'm convinced it'll
help business leaders and
leaders of non-profits and whatever
people need
cool another zonovan zondervan
publication great great thing all right
so tell us the story behind this book
you're you're leading one of the largest
churches in america today your staff is
what size today
uh it's uh close to a thousand or so
okay she got about the same size group
we got over here except yours are spread
all over
right right well yeah the uh story
behind the book dave uh uh
we we talk about it and uh if i could
say this like the ramsey organization
you guys have of it have it for sure
some people might say we're all full of
it but
yeah
if you uh if you went back in time we
started we were one of the churches that
started doing church in multiple
locations early on and we had the
craziest thing we had
buildings that were almost exactly the
same worship music that was almost the
same teaching that was the same the
staff was trained the same way
volunteers the same way
and the results were really really
different we'd walk into one and there'd
be this kind of
vibrant faith and anticipation and vibe
and hope and
a buzz and we'd walk into another one
with the same contributing factors and
it would feel
more dead more lifeless and so we
started saying that the language just
evolved around it we said well this
place has it and this one doesn't and so
we started asking ourself what is it
and it's it's a complicated question to
answer but for years people been saying
like you know that actor that you know
they're they've got the it factor and so
what we did is we did a real in-depth
organizational study into
um non-profits and businesses and into
leaders and asked what are the what are
the factors that contribute to the it
factor and what are the things that kill
it and it evolved into a book that i
wrote in 2008 and this is a very very
revised and expanded version of the book
called lead like it matters and so i'm
i'm just i can't wait for leaders to
read it i think it'll help you know
parents i think it'll help
leaders in schools and non-profits and
and businesses as well yeah a lot of the
this kind of thing it falls under the
category like we say around here uh
people sometimes ask me when i'm
teaching leadership stuff how do you
motivate people and i say i absolutely
do not do that
i hire motivated people
you cannot light wet wood
you know it just won't you can't win the
kentucky derby with a donkey
so you know it matters the it factor is
a real thing and and they don't have to
the person doesn't have to come in
with the ability to be perfect for sure
because we get nobody to help us and
number two they don't have to come in um
you know complete every single thing you
need for them to be able to do you can
add things to the ingredients to the
person's life but boy they gotta have
they gotta have some basic uh structure
to to the it factor don't they
absolutely and we we talk a lot about
that in the book we cover the the seven
uh consistent factors that we found in
our study of organizations that have it
and so we go into a deep dive and then
some of the new content of the book is
is even around which what you talked
about dave is we there's a chapter
called creating systems that empower it
and so the bottom line is you know
what we have organizationally is a
result of the systems that are in place
and a good system can make an average
team member look great and a bad system
can make a good team member look really
bad and so what we want to do is we want
to put great people
into a great culture that never happens
by accident facilitated by great systems
uh fulfilling a great vision and so we
really talk about all these different
organizational factors that matter so
much
and if we get those things right we're
going to see it in our businesses and
our ministries but it's not guaranteed
that it's going to stay there and i
would guess you know ken you've probably
seen it as well in the team you work
with there are times when things are
humming and then other seasons when
they're groaning and so we want to try
to learn how to dissect and understand
what's going on
um and bring a real strategic mindset to
these are the factors that help us get
where we want to get and here's what's
here the roadblocks keeping us from it
and so what do we do to help our team
members be successful and i think this
book can can really really be a good aid
to leaders and their teams
craig i i love this book because you
know we it's so practical to our
audience because we have a lot of men
and women who are very serious about
growing in their professional life
growing their income and that comes with
growing their influence and then
responsibility so i have a two-part
question uh as you unpack the qualities
uh that contribute to that it for
leaders themselves
if someone is a zero can they become a
hero in these areas and then detail out
some of those qualities that you uh
detail in the book that we have to
develop to actually grow and truly
maximize our leadership
that's a great question so um and and
even wrapping back to what dave was
saying that he doesn't
tend to motivate he wants to hire
motivated people and in the same way we
talk about in the book um one of the
things we don't really try to do is to
motivate almost implies to push
but inspire is to bring something out of
people and there's a fascinating study
done by bain research
that shows most people when they think
about an inspirational leader they think
of someone kind of like dave who's you
know loud and has big vision and you
know says made that fray
and and we think that's what i have to
be but what if i'm not that so your
question can a zero become that what
bain found is that there's actually 33
different very distinct traits that lead
toward
an inspirational leader and some of them
are things like showing empathy
consistency
following up there's 33 different traits
all you need is one or two of these well
developed and you can be an
inspirational leader so to answer your
question
yes you don't have to look like every
other leader sound like them think like
them there's tons of different traits
where you can exceed
if you just kind of excel in greatness
in one or two areas you can be very very
inspirational and we go into that and
what we found was fascinating as we
study the leaders that have it for
example you can you for years you've
played at the top of your game we found
is that these leaders have almost what
you call like contradictory
um almost opposing extremes and i'll
give you quick examples
like you you are both dave but both of
you guys you're very very confident
you're incredibly confident and at the
same time it almost seems like an
opposite you're humble you're both
confident and you're humble another one
is is you guys you're both very very
driven you like work horses you work
work your brains out but you're also
healthy
if you're not both you're not going to
you may get it but you're not going to
keep it and so we kind of go through
what are those contributing factors that
we can develop in our own leadership and
what are the organizational factors that
we need present you ask about them a few
a couple of them
you have to have great vision where
there is no vision your organization is
going to perish people are going to
perish you've got to have focus a lot of
it a lot of times dave i brought up what
i thought are good ideas to you and
you're like yeah that's a good idea but
we don't do that here here's what we do
and and your focus enables your success
so we go through seven of those ideas of
um what organization can make you great
and then dive into the specific leader
what can you do in your own personal
leadership to go from maybe struggling
to better to become great to have it and
to make a big difference pastor craig
groeschel the new book is lead like it
matters
seven leadership principles for a church
that lasts you can pick it up anywhere
great books are sold
and uh you know you this is obviously
something that you want to dig into
this guy is um he's a practitioner this
is not a think tank
craig is a leader every day one of the
best leaders i know
and uh if you if you actually if you're
leading a thousand people and you've
grown one of the largest churches in
america today uh there's not it's not an
accidental act it didn't just randomly
occur it happened because of great
leadership from men like craig and so
you do want to read this lead like it
matters
well good to talk to you my friend tell
ms amy we said hey and we'll see you
october 22nd at smart conference see you
at smart converse can't wait dave love
you guys
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
health care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
[Music]
[Applause]
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today
one of our favorite things to do on this
show is have people come on and do their
debt-free screams the only thing better
than that is if they come into the lobby
in person and they're here doing their
debt-free stream on the debt-free stage
and the only thing better than that is
when they do it on the debt free stage
in person and they're part of the ramsey
team
and uh gray sanborn is with us his wife
becca has been a member of our team for
about six years and uh my goodness
gracious man that went fast
oh sure did welcome guys you're debt
free how much did you pay off
97
257
all right and how long did this take
about seven years seven years very cool
what kind of debt was that
oh
car and student loan um
medical
okay a lot a lot of student loans
okay all right very very cool now we got
a rule we don't ask incomes because
we've got half the dead gum building
standing around here watching you unfair
to tell all your co-workers what your
incomes are so
we don't do that but uh we do want to
hear the story so um
how in the world
you it looks so you've been here six
years it took seven years so most of the
debt-free journey has been while you're
working here
yes but you started before you came here
tell us the story
yeah
um well let's see um we learned about
budgeting when we got married our
pre-counselor had us read i think it was
total money makeover i like this
counselor
had us do a budget um but it wasn't
really until um
2015
a friend of ours who used to work here
zach bennett he was like hey
uh you guys should take fbu and so he
gave us a kit
and we went to his class in early 2015
and then he convinced gray to start the
process of trying to apply here so
that's kind of when we started our
journey oh okay yeah it is a process to
get on here it's like getting on with
the fbi or the cia we're very difficult
to uh
organization to join but we're really
good to you once you get here so very
cool stuff in six years man yeah
it's been spectacular started with the
smart dollar team go smart dollar
all right there we go yeah all right
then moved over to the data platform
team with ramsey plus
okay there we go
um
and it's been a wild ride yeah
yeah we um we had two kids so we had to
stop and have two stork funds
and our middle daughter had two eye
surgeries
had the uh cash flow some car repairs
some moves so
it's been a long journey yeah yeah yeah
so how long y'all been married
14 and a quarter years yeah okay so half
of that time you used uh just sitting
around with the debt and the other half
of you is getting rid of it
i like it so how does it feel to be free
y'all oh that's amazing to get just to
get that monkey off your back is an
amazing feeling uh you wake up and
you can stand up straighter because you
don't have that stress just
slowly pressing you down
i'm curious
how this environment
encouraged you what it mean to you
because you guys are in this journey you
had several pauses right and things you
had to do this was a tough journey it's
a long time and here you are every day
i'm just curious
what the environment here did or did not
do
for you as you were in the slog
is a building of really weird people and
amazing
really supportive people i've got
a whole bunch of friends co-workers
team members
and
it is
so refreshing to come into work hey i
had this setback i was able to
do some diy on this car i was able to
take
this uh
profit sharing or
anything else and apply it towards debt
and you're celebrated for it and it's so
so such a supportive environment and
i've
grown immensely for it
because everyone here is getting better
constantly over every day
and they press you to get better and
it's spectacular
yeah
he's got the walk the talk t-shirt on
too we had an internal uh thing we
decided that if if we're going to tell
everybody to get out of debt and do the
stuff in financial peace university we
ought to be doing it we got to be
welcome to talk right and so we we got
the whole team back through financial
peace university the whole team checking
their baby steps and leveling up and uh
we've had had quite a campaign we had a
28 million dollar change in position
last year
among team members and tracking uh and
that would be mortgages paid off
investments made savings done debt paid
off and it's pretty incredible among a
thousand people to do that much money
and you guys are obviously on this
journey right in the middle of that walk
the talk thing absolutely uh over the
past
uh over the last year and a half of our
journey uh we paid off seventy thousand
dollars worth of debt good yeah yeah
yeah like all of a sudden other than
yeah we basically
we took that challenge you guys did very
seriously and
um
basically
nose
down
went straight for it yeah didn't see a
single uh
eating out incident
not one of those incidents i love that
it was an incident
did you sell a bunch of stuff i mean
that's a lot of money um we put
basically any money that came
in extra um so any like profit sharing
uh stimulus money any kind of gift money
all of that
went into it uh we did sell a lot of
a lot of stuff oh you're looking at is
gray is there anything that either one
of you regret it was hard you don't
regret it you used it to get out of debt
but it hurt bad to sell it
i don't think it's really oh all right
it's just stuff what was the biggest
thing you sold
oh gosh
i don't know probably probably baby
stuff because we're done okay yeah so
really what you did is a lot of little
stuff yeah little stuff all right
everybody's really happy dave that
they're done with babies when she made
that pronouncement he was very very
excited about that
he stood up a little straighter yeah i
like it yeah
very good you guys very good well listen
the whole team's proud of you we're
honored to have you on our team uh
you're quite a young man you do a great
job and i have been here a long time six
years and we appreciate you and we're
really excited for you
proud of you you're out of debt who is
cheering you on other than your
co-workers and your wife uh my family uh
her friends
we've got good community around here
and
yeah yeah and i posted monthly updates
to social media
and so we had people all over the
country who were
cheering us on very cool good and you
brought the kiddos with you bring them
up what are their names and ages we've
got evelyn seven
nora who just turned five yesterday
and liza
all right liza she's almost too weak
very cool very cool have they been
practicing their debt free screen a
little bit maybe a little bit all right
good stuff
all right evelyn norah eliza get ready
gray and becca
man grace unborn team member here for
the last six years 97 000 paid off in
seven years count it down let's hear a
debt free scream
three
two
one
[Applause]
and the crowd goes wild
i love it
love it love it love it that is so
fabulous
uh
man
you know i i often tell our team in the
staff meeting it would be a shame for
you to work here all these years and not
actually have done the stuff we teach
and you know get out of debt become
wealthy and make sure you have your
insurance in place and your wills and
all that kind of stuff i mean we're you
know we're kind of on you about it it's
not it's not like it's a you know like
it's a requirement to work here we just
want you to win we love you it's that
simple so uh hey
if you ever find yourself uh saying one
day one day i will be out of debt one
day i'll get a house one day i'm going
to be happy with my career well you may
want to come to our
ah man the smart conference it is coming
up in dallas craig groschel just a few
minutes ago we'll be speaking on he and
his wife amy on marriage kevin coleman
uh number one best-selling author will
be speaking on
a career i'll be speaking george
campbell rachel cruz
um
dr john deloney uh
man christina ellis lots of surprises
and extras coming it's only 39 it's all
day long on october 22nd in dallas you
can still get your tickets and you
should get them soon if you want to go
because we are approaching a sellout
ramseysolutions.com events and check it
out this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author of the book
paycheck to purpose
is my co-host today
thank you for joining us don is with us
in kansas hey don welcome to the ramsey
show
how you doing gentlemen great man how
can we help
i got a question i've been following
your baby steps for a little while me
and wife and
we've got everything paid off debt-free
but the house good and
we
we've been paying extra on the house
but i know you say to pump the brakes
you know i'm transferring my post 911 gi
bill to my kids
for college so we've got that taken care
of
um
but i'm wondering if it makes sense with
the way the markets are right now and
we're locked in at 1.75 on our mortgage
yeah to just pay the minimum
and then maybe take that extra and
invest it or to make more sense to go
ahead and just knock it out
you know
and
get it off our chest
baby step four is 15 of your income
going into retirement five is kids
college everything else goes on six to
pay off the house as soon as possible
now okay here here's the reason i'm
gonna stick with that
um because it works
so i'm gonna stick with it when we
studied the 10
167 millionaires with the largest study
of millionaires ever done in north
america
we found they typically had the people
that have one to five million dollar net
worth their first one to five million
dollars
they typically had two major components
to that
one was a wonderfully funded 401k roth
ira
and this two was a paid for house
the number of those millionaires that
told us
that they maximized their investing by
not paying off their house
was
minuscule
it was approaching zero
so the vast majority of those people who
built wealth went ahead and paid off the
house
and so
they didn't try to play the downside on
the market i like your style
that while everybody else is freaking
out and running you're going to run into
the burning building which i like i i
agree with your math analysis i think
your problem the market's on sale it's a
good time to buy it and if i got a 1.75
yeah
i really kind of like the way you're
thinking but
i'm gonna stick with this
basic idea
that over time continues to work which
is get the house paid off and fund your
retirement and then fund everything
is maxed out and baby step 7 after the
house has paid off so
you're going to just be glad that house
is paid off later
yeah
again dave the data and then just you
for 30 years it works and you know some
people go well i'm going to try to play
the math this way and at the end of the
day that house is going to be a
tremendous investment and i think a much
more stable investment than playing the
stock market obviously i mean you're
going to have both you're both going and
that's fine and i do i both
but um the i'm just gonna
the temptation to
buy the mutual funds while they're on
sale is real yeah
and that's the right way to look at the
situation that we're in in the economy
right now instead of going oh god i
gotta cash out no that's the exact wrong
way to look at it both cases i'm still
gonna tell you do the same thing but i'm
dealing with different emotions and you
know one is run into it what is it
buffett says be greedy when others are
cautious and cautious when others are
greedy
and he doesn't mean greedy like
no he means like just be aggressive with
your investing kenny is with us kenny's
in dixon tennessee hi kenny how are you
i'm good sir how are you better than we
deserve what's up
well
i can't i can't hear you your phone's
screwing up can you talk directly into
it or get it where to work
yes sir can you hear me now yes sir
that's much better
i apologize i began my firefighting
career my grandfather got me into it
when i was 13 years old
when i got old enough i chose that
career path and i've been in it ever
since i've been involved in firefighting
ems emergency management for a long time
now and unfortunately
that is a career that does not pay very
much
my wife and i are in about 83 thousand
dollars for the debt
we journeyed down the uh the ramsey plan
and
we are starting baby step two and we're
starting to snowball stuff we want to go
to the financial peace university but
unfortunately where we are right now is
just not a possibility my question for
you is at what point in time you step
back and look at your career choice
and something that you love
and say this is not going to be
financially possible
you give up something that you love a
career that you love to have financial
peace in the future
it was something that you love yeah are
you working three your phone's still
screwing up are you working 72 on 72 off
no sir i work 16 on 48 off
oh okay
so what's your side hustle
uh we actually do door dash and amazon
flex
is that the because i know a lot of
firemen that have really good small
businesses
that they work in their downtime
yeah i thought about that i know one guy
made 150 grand building decks last year
i'm not that handy okay yeah but you
have other talent so kenny there is a
false narrative that's swirling around
in your head that says that you have to
give up being a fireman that you love
in order to get out of this debt and
then beyond the debt have financial
peace i mean we've we've talked to
thousands of people who have made less
than you and have paid off debt so you
can pay off the debt but dave is is
leaning the right direction here with
you which is what can you do what talent
do you bring to the table
that allows you you'd have to be handy
but what else can you do in that off
time to maybe double your income i don't
think that's a pie in the sky idea
what could you do what pops into your
mind i thought about looking into
security work
great
but you need more ideas like how about
five or six different ideas and you
start to go can i get paid uh what can i
look at when i get paid hourly if you
just break that down as a fireman what
could you do in other places where
you've got relationships you've got some
skill set and experience you're bringing
to the table because using that fireman
schedule to your benefit is the better
play i don't think you have to choose to
walk away from being a fireman because
here's the reality if you try to go to a
different career path kenny
there's probably some getting qualified
that's involved here that's time and
money
and you said you don't have any money so
i'm looking at a better side hustle and
using that time wisely you and your wife
you can do this yeah i know you can do
it and but it is
you know um
and
the other thing too is
it may be that a move towards a more
metropolitan area
uh the rural fire departments
you know they don't pay as much that's
correct in a lot of cases not every case
but uh firemen in uh that with the kind
of experience he's got in
uh across the board with ems and
everything else emts and everything else
he can um
he could move
into a more populated area and possibly
it really increases income yeah now
that's a major choice because i'm sure
his roots run deep in that community
but um
but that that's a possibility sometimes
you have to do that if you're going to
stay in so you know there's different
things you can trade off here
but you don't have to trade off
financial peace university we'll give
that to you yes we'll put you through
and uh you lied you can't afford it you
just didn't want to spend it but i'll
give it to you anyway
i want you to go through and i want you
to go through the nine lessons and get
in a group and make sure your spouse is
going through it with you and get on a
budget but let's do something that is a
more lasting
i mean there's nothing wrong with
doordash as a short-term game no but
that's not a 10-year play no well when
you are intense gazelle intensity and
you're going to get real familiar with
that in financial peace university you
have to say how much time am i spending
in the car delivering and then what am i
actually making because see you're not
just getting paid to deliver you also
have an expense of gas
maintenance issues so where can i
maximize my time for the most amount of
money because you will get to a stage
very soon this is a season not a
sentence kenny you're in a season of
hustle and and you guys can get through
this and then you'll love getting back
into that full-time fireman work but
right now
skills
are simply shovels to just dig dig dig
and get out of this there you go go get
paid the most you can get paid
that's how that works
ken coleman ramsey personality my
co-host today
james and andrew and zach and ben and
austin
and will in the booth with kelly i am
dave ramsey your host we'll be back
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsay network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work they
love and create actual amazing
relationships you call we have questions
about your life we'll help ken coleman
ramsey personality
host of the ken coleman show number one
best-selling author of the book paycheck
to purpose is my co-host today thank you
for joining us america we're so glad you
are here triple eight eight two five
five
kathy's in tyler texas hi kathy how are
you
hi i'm good thank you good how can we
help
um i was widowed eight months ago and
what happened
oh my husband had covered pneumonia and
threw a clot
yeah
how old died in 34 minutes
63 and
very healthy did 80 push-ups a day and
ran two miles a day wow how old was he
63. oh my goodness i'm so sorry
thank you i'm too i'm
just still
in the moment stage but i
am coming to realize that i need to
figure out my finances
and he provided really well i have i
have 1.6 million in investments i have
200 000 in the bank that's life
insurance i'm living on
i'm wanting i am an rn i won't get
vaccinated should i go back to work 160
000 mortgage that i had planned to go
back to work and pay off early didn't
happen um should i draw social security
early on his i get about 75
i'm 60 and i can't draw till 67 if i
don't draw
social security either way is fine it's
irrelevant to the discussion
um okay because you know you got 1.6
million
so i mean social insecurity is not going
to change your life one way or the other
if you get it now you get it later or
you never get it your life's still going
to be about what it is with the money
you've got so
the bigger question i've got is just
emotionally
as a part of the healing process
does work help
i currently volunteer as a nurse and yes
it does
but i don't know if it's work if it
will be a lot more stressful than than
if it's volunteering
oh well
here's the thing
whatever you're doing you don't need
that's correct the money
and so you're not going to be in a toxic
situation
or a high stress situation for very long
because you wouldn't need to be you
would just say i think i'm done right so
yeah um
i don't know what how you're wired um
most people
it does us good to put our hand to
something
and you obviously enjoy nursing and are
good at it
so i kind of just think
it's not really anything to do with the
money it's just got to do with kathy
what kind of volunteer work are you
doing
i work at a family
family practice clinic that serves the
uninsured yeah
and they don't require a vax
no no they're happy to get it i just
think you need to challenge you know
this this idea that the only type of
work you can do as an rn is going to
require that you're going to do your
homework there in that area and you
certainly have the connections you know
where to check i would check that and i
think
i think maybe part time or take a take a
full-time gig for a while knowing that
you have walkaway power as dave said you
don't need the money so you don't need
to worry about doing too much and i
tiptoe into it a little bit and hang out
with some other nurses tell them your
situation what you'd like to do
i know there's a tremendous need in the
industry across the board a lot of
burnout in that field so if you find the
right scenario i think you get the best
of both worlds you can make some money
pay off the house
um you can just be engaged and be
involved as you continue to heal how
much you're serving how much do you need
a year to live
um i was planning on being doing about
60 a year to live
i've currently spent right at 40 this
year
but i'm cutting back i had a lot of
travel that had to happen
um
i think i could realistically live on
between 45 and 50.
i think 60 is fine or more 80 whatever
the the point is the 200 will last a
while doing that without even touching
your retirement if you don't work
if you do work correct you know um
you could probably make 80 pretty easy
couldn't you
yes oh yes yeah
assuming again assuming you find
something that's not
uh going to violate your personal
medical freedoms
in the process which is what you're
requiring what you're requiring and i'm
i don't disagree with you on that
so um
you know and you know the medical world
as you know is there's a
there's so many different things you can
do as an rn
oh yes yes i did home care before i
before i quit work when i had kids and
i don't think i want to do that again
with gas and everything um but i i do
love being a nurse so i definitely want
to do it again
you're a caregiver and it will be good
for your broken heart yep yes definitely
my husband lives it my husband was a
family nurse practitioner so it's just
in us yeah you know and then the the the
the benefit is on top of that oh and
you're making money you know too so but
to me you know you could you can set
this 1.6 million with a you know sit
down with one of our smartvestor pros or
your advisor and um you can pull 100 off
of that for the rest of your life and
never touch it
because it automatically it ought to
make 160 to 200 000 a year
if it makes ten percent if it makes ten
percent right now well on average the
stock market is average between ten and
twelve percent long haul and so on
average you know it ought to make you uh
you know 150 200 000 a year and if you
pull 100 off you know you're not going
to hurt anything and so that's what i
mean by social security is irrelevant
if you want to take it fine if you don't
want to take it fine and if you want to
go to work fine
that's why i start discussing work
through from a different perspective
um
i mean we're about same age or something
happening to sharon i can promise you
i'm working
uh not to medicate and not not in a sick
way or something like that but just
to uh stay connected to other humans to
not sit at home and you don't want to
sit at home watch netflix i mean it's
just a bad idea yeah and so um
you know but the volunteer part's okay
if you wanna just do that that's okay if
you decide you don't wanna do this but i
think you look for the right
fit where it's a good environment
quality people
they're not requiring that you violate
that they they violate your medical
freedoms with their requirements
and um
you know the uh
any you know and again there's no hurry
if it takes you four or five months to
stumble into that that'd be okay and
and if you work there a little while and
you go you know what i'm not having fun
i'm out of here
you got walkaway power as ken said and
that's i think that's
beautiful
sorry for your loss yes very much i'm
sorry
so that's a tough tough thing to walk
through
and um
yeah the great news is you all have done
a wonderful job with your finances
and i have become millionaires as nurses
there you go
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
thank you for joining us and uh
ken you're all about
passion yeah uh dave you know i mean i'm
i'm super super convinced that uh that
uh my purpose i talk about purpose and
work a lot but i think my purpose is to
give away your money dave i used to say
that for many years when i got to host
live events i would tell the audience i
have the spiritual gift of giving away
dave's money
because i was the guy well everybody
everybody i have a gift yeah and so i
feel like that purpose is back uh
so uh i am super excited to announce our
ramsey cash giveaway is back we're
giving away five hundred dollars every
week and a grand prize of three thousand
dollars so like free money in the
inflation time it's free money time it's
free money time it's free money time
help you with your groceries you can pay
off debt you can add it to your
investments that's correct so the 3000
is given away in the month of august and
the 500 is every week so here's how you
enter super easy go to
ramseysolutions.com
giveaway that's
ramsaysolutions.comgiveaway and you can
enter every day for extra chances to win
all month long no purchase is required
but you've got to be 18
or older to win so remember the website
is ramsey solutions dot com slash
giveaway our question of the day comes
from blinds.com they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee
that means if you screw it up
you mismeasure you pick the wrong color
like i've done
they will remake your window blinds for
free you get free samples free shipping
new promos all the time this is an
incredible american company
blinds.com use the promo code ramsey and
you'll get the best deal today's
question comes from robert in virginia
i'm 40 years old working for the
government earning 80 thousand dollars
but i absolutely hate it
don't be unclear robert i don't know why
we're laughing i don't know i'm sorry
that we're amused by that it's just his
phrasing you can feel it you can feel it
popping off the page i hate my job
that's right uh he's been there for 15
years and he says i cannot break into
management they've promoted someone with
no experience or education over me a
couple of years ago i've always wanted
to get into tech and coding but i know
those jobs don't initially pay as much
as i make now
i'm going to push back on that one
momentarily i have about a hundred
thousand dollars in debt if i left my
job and took my pension i would receive
eighty five thousand dollars and have
another twenty thousand in an ira
this would give me the opportunity to be
debt free and start fresh should i quit
and start fresh or stay where it's safe
and keep trying to chip away at the debt
so number one don't stay where you are
because you already are resenting this
current place of employment you've been
overlooked and that's very personal to
you and so you're going to decay your
soul will decay if you stay now before
you quit though i want you to get
qualified
and i endorse a wonderful organization
called bethel tech it's a nine month
program
you can cash flow your way through it
and they are having students starting at
68 to 70 thousand dollars a year that's
slightly below what you make but dave if
he's got the uh uh the 85k and the 20k
and the ira i'll let you address that on
the debt so nine months he becomes a dev
one that's exactly right now he's on his
way and you're talking about one is a
1780 k right now yep that's right and um
you can step into that and then you step
out
uh but the good news is if you'll
continue to develop those code skills
and move from to dev2 to f3 let's start
learning platform start learning some of
the other things that are out there in
the tech world continue to grow in that
that you know we got guys in this
building they're making a couple hundred
grand that's correct and we see lots of
them yes programmers are still in demand
software engineer is a big deal and so
um
uh the the the market is going to get
more competitive there it's been a um
it's been kind of a uh
an employee's market uh for the last
little while
and uh
but it's
a lot of this recession is slowing
things down we're gonna see some of
these developers on the street that's
correct and um so but yeah but i still
would go do this yeah so stay in the
government job now he can do bethel tech
while he's got a full-time job
absolutely okay you're doing it online
that's where all their students do it's
a nine-month program by the way they
give ramsey show listeners a discount
off of the 15 000. so
uh i got to spend some time with the
guys the wonderful founder of that a
while back they're good people yeah well
we're seeing great results we're seeing
people that are uh starting jobs in the
75 80 000 range uh they're cash
we're using them to we are to to put to
fill some of our developer needs that's
right as well so um
you know internally so in addition to
they became an advertiser on your show
but they're good they're good guys and
that's a valid thing yeah go to code
school dude yes definitely definitely
get out of the state job but do not quit
until you're qualified and then you got
something else to step onto i just
always want to make sure people here
we're not a big fan of jumping off a
cliff
that's right this time next year you're
in the new job yep and uh the debt free
can be debt free would you advise that
though dave on the cashing out of the
pension
no pay off his debt no you're going to
roll that pension
into a 401k right or into an ira yeah uh
to keep from having the taxes on it and
the penalties and everything no you
don't want to do that you want to cash
it out but uh but you can you can work
your way through the debt we just got to
get you where you're not miserable first
and um
that's the thing and
lots lots of opportunity there dave is
with us dave is in detroit hi dave
welcome to the ramsey show
welcome to you guys greg glad to um talk
to you guys today i have a situation
where i have a company that approached
me about buying my about acquiring my
company
and
i'm just wondering what type of
questions that
i should ask them and what type of
questions they're going to ask me do you
want to sell it at this stuff
well i'm getting close to 60 and that
was my purpose to be retired by the time
i was 60. cool okay
if they got a
you know like a
an offer memorandum or a letter of
intent or anything with a dollar amount
on it
not not yet
um
roughly my gross profit last year was
right around 750 so i'm figuring it's
worth right around 3.3 million to 3.5
the company is completely debt free i'm
completely debt free i have a retirement
of 500 grand and my house is worth
almost a million yeah
so you walk away three million dollars
cash you're gone right
probably yeah i would no not probably i
would be yeah
i'd be out of dodge what kind of company
what do you do
construction supplies good for you i go
around and calling
people out in the industry and that
the thing is it's just
you know the emotion side of it and all
that i know you've been through some of
that and
just trying to get a perspective of
of that
uh help me what you're talking about
like my emotion is woohoo you want to
retire you got three million bucks
what's the emotion
emotion is um they'd probably want me to
work two more years afterwards oh
okay
all right do you want to do that sure
not really okay then that becomes part
of the negotiation you know okay would
you take you know if they say okay you
know we'll give you 3.3
uh if you work two years we'll give you
three if you don't you're probably gonna
take the three and go
yep okay you know i mean
just start talking that through with
them and
you want to stay long enough to ensure
the asset that they bought is valuable
to them
but uh you know that you
customarily that would be a year
anything past that they're starting to
buy you
with the deal okay that's the question i
have dave that's going to get that's
going to get more expensive yeah are you
like 95
65 55 of the relationships with your
customers or you have other people that
are selling
no i am pretty much doing
everything with my company i work about
72 hours in five days i do all the
selling all the billing all the delivery
and
well they want to make sure that they
want to make sure you bring up the next
guy on the connection delivering and
billing is something they can take on
immediately if they're in the same
industry or you know but the selling and
the relationships that's what's valuable
and they want to they want you to be
there i mean you would if you were
buying it you'd want to be keep the guy
long enough to make sure that connection
happens because if all those connections
go sideways
because you're out of there too soon
then then they bought a bag of dirt they
didn't buy anything
right yeah and that's what i don't want
to happen i mean it's gonna get bought
out i'd like to see it continue with
with all of that yeah
so i mean it'll take a year when you
think to get to get the new guy in the
saddle and you be riding with him
oh yeah i wouldn't i'd work one at least
a year certainly
yeah so i just think you begin the
discussion with these guys and
you know make sure they're not thinking
they're going to buy it for a million
and you're going to work five years
because i think that the discussion's
over at that point
but because we're not we're not even
we're not even the same ballpark but if
we can get the same ballpark we can
start a discussion and negotiation and
say hey you know this is i want you guys
to win i don't want to rip you off but
i'm walking out of here home by the way
you are walking out of there with cash
cash
not terms not they're going to pay you
on the come
cash
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage matthew
and caitlin are with us hey guys how are
you good how you doing good how are you
great to have you where do you all live
albany new york wow a bit of a haul to
nashville a little bit well we're glad
to have you how much did you pay off
128 000
way to go and your how long did this
take 40 months wow and your range of
income during that time between 95 000
and 122 000. cool what do y'all do for a
living i'm work at new york state at the
insurance fund as an internal auditor
okay and i'm an athletic business
manager for the uh university at albany
all great danes yeah
go great danes i love it what kind of
debt was the 128 thousand so uh
it was 12 000 was a car loan because we
were normal car loans uh
house renovation and uh student loans
was uh 88 000.
so wow
okay how long y'all been married
uh four years okay
so
sometime shortly after marriage you
looked at this mess and went uh we need
to clean this up what happened tell me
the story so it was actually before we
got married okay my sister's here and uh
they actually were here seven years ago
and did their debt free screen oh fun
and uh we uh
we knew once we got engaged we didn't
wanna we didn't want finances to be the
root of problems so
we decided uh we were gonna cash flow
our wedding
when we did that and uh that was about
20 000 that was not included in our debt
and then right after we got married we
decided
uh we were gonna take this uh by the
bull by the horns basically yeah and uh
we just basically we're just gonna sell
intense ever since then
so a little over three years boom 128
000 is gone yeah yep life-changing yeah
yeah and how did you get connected up
with us so my sister was was a primary
example uh doing their debt free scream
and then it was actually funny when we
walked into the studio today we had our
you had our pastor on pastor craig yeah
so we go to life church in albany yeah
they uh they did a life group there and
we got in into that and we started
leading uh life groups as well
and uh
life churches life groups all went
through financial peace university yes
yeah and i also wanted to give a shout
out to one of our attendees john and
maria boiler who paid off uh 57 000 of
debt in about two years yeah
very cool in your group then yeah part
of our group so they were the first ones
that we helped lead to uh debt free as
well okay so you led a group yeah oh wow
okay thank you it was a good motivator
when we were going through baby step two
to keep going by leading others to do
the same yeah yeah it does and it's kind
of hard to not do the stuff if you're
leading because it makes you a hypocrite
yes exactly
yeah i was going to ask you specifically
can you share maybe a story or a moment
maybe where you saw yourself as leaders
in in that community it spurred you on
maybe when you needed it well so when we
did our first group i felt like
you know there were a lot of people that
were wishy-washy but we kept like
telling them about matt's sister and his
brother-in-law and how this program
really does work and how like if you
just keep pushing through it it will get
you to the end
and so like you know we saw how it
worked in the first group that we went
through with other like other people who
were going through it the first time so
then when we were able to do it the
second time we were able to help our
friends to like really push forward and
to get debt free as well so it's just
yeah love that very very cool all right
when you get right down to it and
somebody's sitting in the group or one
of your friends asks uh you paid off 128
000 how did you do that what do you tell
them the key to getting out of that is
so i would say working hard i mean there
were nights and weekends and there were
so she worked
at jimmy john's in a sub shop for a
couple years
most recently even even with us being
debt-free we're still doing some of
these things she she's making pizzas on
the side i i've left high school
football for uh about 12 years now so
i've used that income as well to help as
a side hustle
but just basically working hard
just saying gazelle intense and when you
feel like you're falling off the wagon
just you know you just gotta go back to
the roots and because it's hard it is
hard yeah but it's uh
it the reward is definitely greater than
than being in debt i should say proud of
you guys way to go
very very very well done excellent
excellent job so now that you're
completely done how's it feel
it's so great we moved on to baby step
three and now we're doing baby step 3b
where we're saving up for a house so
that's like our next step
just walking right through the baby step
yep walking through them very cool good
for y'all hey we got a copy of baby
steps millionaires for you that's going
to be the next chapter in your story for
sure thank you for leading the classes
and thank you for being you you did a
great job i'm proud of you thank you
thank you really got taken control in
your life early in your marriage here
you got all kinds of bright future ahead
of you yeah very very very well done
good good stuff also we got another copy
of financial peace university for you a
mem one year membership you'll be able
to give that away as you lead the class
to somebody thank you since you all have
been through it the new videos are out
with uh dr john deloney and rachel cruz
and george campbell and me i think it's
the best fpu we've ever done right now
and uh so i'm real proud of it but yeah
make sure
as you continue to lead the classes
that'll help you do that and a total
money makeover book you'll find somebody
to give that to too i'm sure but yeah
wonderful wonderful wonderful thank you
guys so much for making the trip down
from albany so proud of you
i got before you count them down i gotta
ask matthew when you're reffing when you
throw a flag do you go up do you just go
straight up or do you throw the flag at
though i gotta know so i i'm uh i'm an
umpire so i'm in with the linebackers
you're in the middle of the act i am so
it's more of a i'm throwing more spot
fouls than i am up in the air but
sometimes you got to throw it way up all
right so i wanted to david he's in the
danger zone he's in between the
linebackers and the line he's got to be
careful not to get run over so yes all
right sorry dave for the interruption
is he a flag up guy or a flag at guy
that these are things i didn't know it
existed he's a spot i needed to know
he's throwing it at the spot i like that
all right all right spotting it yeah
there we go that happened the
the offense happened there yeah all
right matthew and katelyn albany new
york
128 000 paid off in 40 months making 95
to 122. count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two one
[Applause]
[Music]
way to go you guys
way to go
beautiful work
very very very well done pretty
incredible
well that's how it's done ladies and
gentlemen open phones at triple eight
eight two five
five two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your
life and your money candace on facebook
says my husband's preparing to retire
from the army ken after 20 years he's in
cyber security oh
good
uh it's been recommended to get a
professionally made resume considering
he will be applying for jobs a salary
over a hundred thousand he got a quote
for 800 bucks does that sound right uh
it sounds probably right but it's also
ludicrous uh so yes do i think that
people are charging that and getting
that yes but i got to tell you it's
absolutely mind-boggling uh that the
number of times i have hired someone
because the resume is precisely zero so
let's look at the data uh we know that
hiring managers spend about seven and a
half seconds looking at a resume so it
doesn't have to be eight hundred dollars
worth we actually have that's 100 a
second yes i was getting yes that's
exactly what i was thinking so uh first
of all ramsey solutions has a wonderful
free template at ken coleman.com and uh
so you just go check that out it works
we've had people get hired at fortune 50
companies uh we also have resume
templates if you like the free version
uh that's again at kencoleman.com it's
one of our ramsey solutions resources we
charge for the templates for the
templates but not the free one that's
800 bucks no it's
9.99 not eight hundred dollars that's
correct so don't pay eight hundred
dollars no i don't care if you buy it or
not
don't do that that's crazy uh he's got a
world-class
record and all you need is a clean
easy to understand resume it's just not
worth that that's correct i did cyber
security in the army that's all it's got
to say right there that's it oh people
will get it after that they will know
from there
800.
no
never
and here's the thing the way she worded
this she's she's ready to buy it oh yeah
she's she's i mean he's gonna be getting
a big job he ought to spend some money
on the resume
nope
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day proverbs 21 25
the desire of the sluggard kills him
for his hands refuse to labor
jim rohn says successful people do what
unsuccessful people are not willing to
do
don't wish it were easier wish you were
better
game on yeah the legend dropping it yeah
ken coleman ramsey personality my
co-host today julie is in dallas hi
julie how are you
hi ken and dave
hey what's up um um i'm good so we are a
newer military family and we'll be
leaving the dallas area next may
um and we currently own a home here um
and so we're kind of wondering do we
sell the house or do we keep it as a
rental property okay
no you don't want long-distance
landlords
you don't want a long-distance landlord
okay where are you moving to
um still unsure
okay well give me a guess uh georgia or
oklahoma okay you're living in georgia
and you get ready to buy a rental house
you're gonna buy a rental house in
georgia you're gonna buy one in dallas
so the only way you ended up with the
dallas rental property was by default
not by plan
okay
you don't want to back into being a
landlord you want to you want the
property within a you know within your
city and you're within driving range of
your area get dialed in there
that kind of thing that's where you want
it to be and so long distance
landlording is um
it's bad for business thanks for your
service by the way we appreciate it all
right it looks like robertson in los
angeles hey robert welcome to the ramsey
show
hi thank you for accepting my call um
nervous uh okay so uh my question is um
i got um reached out to by a recruiter a
third party recruiter that this
aerospace company hired i really love
where i work but i don't know what
questions to ask when i talk to this
direct hire position recruiter
what do you love most about where you
work
the people um
i i i'm a military i used to be an army
for five years and now i work for the
space force as a contractor so i just
love
the space you love the space camaraderie
would you say that you love the work or
let's say 75 percent of your day do you
love what you're doing
yes yes i would say so i mean it's
um why would you listen i
think well this new position is
a leadership position an entire pain
sure so the reason i asked you robert
those first two questions is that is the
base of the questions that you will ask
this recruiter and if you get in an
interview process your questions have to
be
determining
if this new opportunity
has all of the ingredients or has that
list
of the things that you love you don't
want to just take a leadership
opportunity for the sake of taking the
leadership opportunity if it is in a
culture
um that doesn't have the kind of people
that you love to be around if it doesn't
include the work that you love to do now
you don't want to be the leader of a
bunch of doofuses that's right or lead
underneath people that are doofuses so
it's okay to kick the tires and have a
conversation but you asked what
questions should you ask questions
designed to get you the answers that you
need to know is this the kind of place
that i'm in now is it similar enough to
go okay this makes sense for the things
that i care about yeah leadership
opportunity and money will both go away
rapidly if you get into a toxic
environment
and that that was my concern and i'm
trying to weed that out yeah
so
take your time yeah here's a couple
sample questions to get to what you were
actually identifying so i would describe
i would ask a question like this how
would you describe the culture here is
it open-ended so they can't give you a
yes or no answer and if they start doing
that politics speak you ever seen a
politician on tv never answer the
question yes okay so hey that's a bad
sign because a healthy leader and a
place where there's intentional culture
and you ask that question two things
happen number one they give you a real
description and number two they're
impressed with the question that you
asked so that's one thing to determine
how do they
what's the culture like how do you treat
people what what do you as leaders value
for the people that work here here's
another sample question
describe the person who wins in this
organization
same exact result you're going to learn
as much about them and then they're
going to be impressed
with the kind of question you asked so
remember this and i say this to people
all the time dave
the interview process is just as much
for you the job seeker as it is for the
potential employer don't forget that
yeah and and listen it is
how old are you
33.
it is at any age
um so i'm 62 you're 33.
there is not you don't reach a point in
your career or your life
that someone reaching out to you and
saying
you're valuable
is not kind of
nice yeah it's very flattering it's
flattering it feels good to be wanted
to be respected
and just the act of being recruited is a
uh is flattering isn't it feels good
okay don't confuse that
affirmation that the recruiter is giving
you with the fact that there may or may
not be a good job on the other side of
this
so go go in here with some very
analytical
take your time
really dig in
because you you got a good spot
and just because some goober called you
off a linkedin or whatever does not mean
that you need to leave
and you may be able to develop
leadership where
opportunities where you are well you
should be looking for it i love that
dave because you know that was that was
robert's response hey it's a leadership
opportunity well hey go sit down with
your current leaders and go hey
i want to grow here i love this company
here's why i love this company and then
say
i know i got to earn it so as my leader
what do you think that i need to do tell
me what i could do to add value and let
them create a plan for you and you might
find yourself climbing the ladder where
you are and so uh but but i love that
you're kicking the tires but remember
you're in total control here you're the
one asking the questions if it doesn't
feel right trust that feeling we joke
about that feeling you know
sharon ramsey's got a world-class
feeling that you've told us about but
you know that neuroscience has actually
proven that that is the same thing that
feeling that we have is our brain
sending a physical signal to our body so
trust that feeling yeah
absolutely
you know robert it occurs to me um
that you're not going to do well in a
leadership position until you've learned
to lead
and um i'm going to give you a book
recommendation by my friend seth godin
his favorite book he ever wrote is
called uh linchpin yeah great and i
would read linchpin
and basically what it might say is
there's several kinds of leaders there's
leaders that are given a title and that
puts them in charge which doesn't really
make you a leader makes you a boss then
you have the opportunity to lead from
that position but you can lead
up yes you can lead around
you you can you know by becoming a
leadership john maxwell says his
influence yes and so become influential
do things where you're serving helping
lifting
uh other people and uh and create
influence what you dave has just
described is in order to learn how to
lead you've got to learn how to follow
and i i think following well learning to
hey i'm going to respect the authority
i'm going to serve the authority i'm
going to do all those things that you
talked about by the way john maxwell has
a book that addresses that's called a
360 degree leader this idea of leading
all the way around you through
simply being influential and i you know
i think learning how to follow and then
writing things down hey this is what i
appreciate about my current leader
this i would probably do differently
take notes as a follower take notes so
that when you get the opportunity to
lead you've got some real life
experience i know that when a leader did
this for me i excelled i know that when
a leader
did this
i can tell you exactly
where i was standing
at 23 years old
the first time i experienced a leader
that i knew
actually cared about me that's powerful
i know where i know i know exactly where
i'm standing where were you
we were i was working for a
new home
uh company on selling homes and the big
boss came in and we were walking between
the models
and uh looking we had three model homes
and we're walking between two of the
models and we're between the second one
and the third one i can show you the
sidewalk that's that's he stopped and
turned and started asking questions
about me and you could feel it and see
it in his eyes that he actually did care
and i i was blown away because i've
never worked for anybody like that
before
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
you